let's talk about how strange confusing
and stressful this pandemic has been for
people because we probably don't talk
about it enough
social distancing the world economy a
standstill a rising global death toll
none of it is normal there's no way to
come out of this normal at least not
having something affecting your psyche
we put a call out to our viewers to find
out how you're feeling some of us are
bored tired grateful productive paranoid
inspired or just plain done with it the
copy of nineteen fighters is not only
attacking our physical health is also
increasing psychological cycling and
while we worry about keeping the virus
away and staying physically fit how do
we protect our mental health too
[Music]
in some parts of the world lockdowns
have stretched on for weeks even months
there's talk of more down a road and in
countries where restrictions are being
lifted we're still keeping our distance
and we're not socializing the way we
used to the consensus is all of that is
having an effect on us and our mental
health you've probably heard that human
beings are considered social animals
well that's based on science humans are
the most vulnerable species at birth and
meat rely on others for survival our
readings have adapted to having others
as our baseline and so when this lack of
proximity to trusted others is absent
then it puts us in a heightened state of
alert essentially our brains are
hard-wired to feel safe knowing we can
turn to others if we need to so whenever
we feel lonely the fight-or-flight area
in our brain releases stress hormones
like adrenaline into our nervous system
and if we stay in that state of alert
for a long time it starts having a
physical effect on our body like on our
digestive and immune systems the risk of
heart attack stroke and type 2 diabetes
can also go up some studies show that
loneliness can even shorten your life
what we found was that loneliness was
associated with a 26% increase risk for
earlier death social isolation at 29%
and living alone a 32% but it's not just
isolation that's stressing out our
brains and bodies it's everything
now the number of credit iris cases
globally has crossed 4 million then
Kelowna readers full of COBIT banks
all anyone talks about is the pandemic
we're overwhelmed by constant news
updates some of them true and some of
them false and that information overload
can cause anxiety for some of us I think
we have this kind of belief that we can
try to control this anxiety but
excessively worrying about that
consuming more and more information and
that might actually feed into the
anxiety but most things seem to be out
of our control
and that uncertainty is wearing people
down fear and anxiety stress these are
all incredibly normal responses to this
situation there are a lot of unknowns
anxiety is a natural reaction to
something that is uncertain anyway and
this pandemic is the most uncertain time
that any of us have lived through maybe
you're having trouble sleeping or you
just feel a bit weird almost like it's
Groundhog Day I'm reliving the same day
you might be fine one day and feel
totally over at the next a lot depends
on your experience of this pandemic you
might be dealing with trauma after
recovering from the virus maybe you've
lost someone maybe you've lost their job
some people were struggling to put food
on the table even before the lockdown or
maybe you've had to upend your work or
school routine there's already evidence
that young adults and children are
feeling it at Oxford University study
found the one in five children and now
afraid to leave their homes and then
there are those with pre-existing mental
health issues like people with diagnose
depression who might feel particularly
vulnerable right now it's also elderly
people terrified about contracting the
virus and it's health care workers
dealing with the sick and being afraid
of getting sick themselves
[Music]
honestly guys felt like I was working in
a war zone for me to say I don't feel
fear going into a room or anxiety that
my heart doesn't start pounding in my my
stomach doesn't turn is a lie mental
health experts say an entire generation
of medical workers will likely suffer
prolonged psychological effects from
working through this pandemic
it's those prolonged effects that mental
health specialists are worried about
because we just don't know when we'll
see the back of this pandemic yes some
countries are starting to lift the
lockdowns but life isn't exactly going
back to normal and there's no guarantee
that the number of cases won't spike
again the virus is going to stay for a
while it's gonna stay for a few years
even if after we get the vaccine the
vaccine will not eradicate the virus the
vaccine will decrease this transmission
rate this virus basically can go away
but it goes back like seasonal flu that
means that whatever we're feeling now
could last a while after the SARS
epidemic in 2003 people still showed
what's called avoidance behavior a study
found that about one fifth of people
were avoiding public spaces weeks later
one quarter avoided crowded and enclosed
places and just over half still avoided
people who coughed or sneezed I do worry
that there will be continued lingering
fear around being close to others there
are also concerns about other ways
people might respond a report in The
Lancet medical journal says there are
suggestions that the number of deaths by
suicide will rise in Australia for
instance calls to this helpline have
gone up by 40 percent since the pandemic
began but there's not a lot of data yet
linking suicide rates to Kovan 19
specialists we've spoken to say that
first of all people who decide to take
their own life do it for several reasons
not just one that an increase in calls
to support lines doesn't necessarily
indicate any
crease in suicidal actions and that more
people reaching out might actually be a
good thing
in fact some researchers say people who
have already sought mental health
treatment are in a better position to
cope they're actually better prepared
for this isolation in pandemic because
of coping mechanisms and resilience
measures that they've learned in and
passed already there's actually a lot of
research being done to find out what
positive effects might come from this
pandemic the sense of solidarity the
sense of togetherness that may come from
this there may be some comfort in
knowing that others are experiencing
something similar there may be the
potential positive effects of reducing
stigma around this so a greater
willingness to talk about it
seeing mental health and emotional
well-being as a natural part of all of
our lives so anything that's that's more
sort of able to break the stigma is good
from our side so here are a few things
we can do to keep our mental health in
check
pretty good to find ways to kind of have
a little project tasks or little ways to
achieve something throughout today pick
up a phone and check in on family
members friends neighbors the best thing
that you can do is inform yourself with
legitimate sources the easiest way to do
that is to look to the World Health
Organization facts minimize fear
whatever you're feeling you're
definitely not the only one we're all
affected by it and if you're really
struggling it's okay to ask for help
the World Health Organization has an
online campaign called healthy at home
that has lots of advice depending on
where you live you can also get help
online or over the phone and if you're
watching on YouTube we'll leave some
links below this video see you next week
[Music]